what's going on guys this is Rob and it
is convergence time yes we are
officially into week one of our
convergence solicitations and so we're
going to be doing in this video is I'm
going to be doing kind of a review of
the week one solicitation so far and the
reason why is because I want to kind of
talk to you guys about convergence kind
of give you guys a rundown on what's
happening so far but once issue number
two of these two-part stories come out
then we'll actually do the full
explained video on each of these so for
right now this is just kind of a rundown
on what's happening so far and how the
stage is sort of being set for these
various stories that we've been given up
to this point now kicking off our list
of the number one spot is Batman and
Robin number one and what this does is
give us a look at the pre flashpoint
Batman Bruce Wayne and Damian Wayne and
so at this one we're basically looking
at the era whereby Damian Wayne has come
into the life of Batman but nothing's
been rebooted yet in addition to this we
also find that Jason Todd is apparently
the Red Hood and confined in the Gotham
City and this is going to be a common
theme of all these solicitations that
all these all these stories take place
inside Gotham City proper and I would go
as far as to say the reason for this is
because in order for Batman to be
effective he needs to have access to all
of his gadgets and all his gadgets
pretty much reside in Gotham City and
some of Batman's going to make
appearances in any of these stories and
he's gonna have to be inside Gotham City
proper in order for it to make sense but
the fact remains one of the common
themes here is that the domes have
pretty much gone up it encompass each of
these cities and that as a result those
individuals who have superpowers have
lost their powers those individuals who
have powers that are tied into
electronic devices like we'll see what
arsenal later on lose the ability to
control those in addition it seems as
though a year about a year passes or so
between the time the domes come up and
the time that Tilos officially makes his
announcement that we saw in a
convergence issue number one now again
this mostly deals with the idea of Bruce
Wayne and Damian Wayne going about their
normal life but it also really continues
to give us this element of how Bruce
Wayne relates to Damien why Damien does
the kind of things he does so again for
those of you guys who read pre
flashpoint Batman and we're familiar
with Damian Wayne and if you're not I
have a video on Damian Wayne this is
basically a return to those stories a
return to those roots now again we find
that ultimately this comment comes to an
end that Tilos makes his grand
announcement and saying that each
individual in this city
I guess these are these champions in
these cities if they want their cities
to live and if they want to live with
their cities then they're basically
going to have to fight champions from
other realities which is why the domes
are coming down in the first place and
so we find that the this greer batman
and robin end up going against the
extremists of Angoor which again is a
group that we'll talk about next week
once we get into part two of these
stories again assuming that part two of
these stories actually come out next
week now the next in our lineup is
Justice League number one and Justice
League number one initially before I
actually saw the cover of it I thought
it was simply going to be a return to
pre flashpoint Justice League proper
Martian Manhunter Superman so on and so
forth but instead we don't get that
instead as we had seen with the preview
of the offerings that were coming out
for Justice League that we're actually
getting pre flashpoint cetana Supergirl
Jade and Jessie quick which is actually
really kind of a cool concept to have an
all-female lineup of the Justice League
now again much like Batman and Robin
they're simply just dealing with the
ramifications of the domes going up but
joy much like Batman and Robin we also
find that they've lost their abilities
they don't have powers anymore and so as
a result they're basically just kind of
trying to cope with society as a whole
and this is where the story kind of
begins to sort of take a downturn it's
kind of where it begins to falter a
little bit and I wouldn't go as far as
to say it makes it one of the greatest
stories of all time one of the greatest
stories in convergence but we get a
little bit of character development we
actually get to see some really cool
interactions between these these four
women and DC Comics but again much like
we saw with Batman and Robin Tilos
appears he delivers the ominous message
of them having to fight somebody else
and so we ultimately find that this
version of the Justice League is gonna
be going against the flashpoint version
of Aquaman and so this is actually gonna
be a really cool concept because Aquaman
is trying to take Mara from this version
of the Justice League and trying to
basically make her his queen which she's
a little reluctant to do but the fact
remains from here we jump into the third
offering for a convergence this week and
that one is Nightwing and Oracle and
this I think was one of the most
anticipated stories to come out of
convergence because one of the cool
things was that looking at Oracle
Barbara Gordon the role that she
undertook after her paralysis at the
hands of the Joker during The Killing
Joke was a character who was redefined
as being one of the most important
characters and the bat family as opposed
to just kind of being someone that ran
around and beat people up she now had to
find a way to cope with her paralysis
and in doing so made herself an
intrinsic
part of the Batman team now this story
focuses largely on the relationship
between Nightwing and Oracle were the
two of them kind of get together and I
won't go too far into it because it'll
spoil our video for next week but the
fact remains that again Tilos appears
offering his ominous message or making
this ominous message and we end up
learning that that this group that a
Nightwing pre flashpoint and Oracle pre
or I guess Barbara Gordon pre flashpoint
will be going against the flashpoint
version of Hawkman and Hawk woman which
is actually kind of a cool concept in
terms of how they arrive and what it is
they offer tonight wing and to Barbara
Gordon now coming into the number-4 spot
is Speed Force number one and a lot of
people said they really didn't felt like
anything happened in speed force number
one they felt like it was a slow story
nothing really took place here I beg to
differ
I thought Speed Force number one was a
great story again we know that Barry
Allen has his connection to the Speed
Force I'm sorry but not very Allen
Wally West Wally West I'm so I'm so used
to saying Barry Allen Wally West the
return of Wally West he loses his
connection to the Speed Force as a
result of the domes going up and so as a
result he's no longer super fast one of
the really cool things here is that
where everybody else is kind of resigned
themselves to the fate of being stuck in
this dome with no escape he's still
trying to find a way to get out now of
course again one steelo's makes his
message known the domes come down and
that's one of the really cool things
here is when the domes come down
everybody gets their powers back all the
powers come back and so Wally West
regains his connection to the Speed
Force now one of the downsides to this
story and one of the things that I think
a lot of pre flashpoint Wally West fans
will look at is they're not a big fan of
Wally West's Wally West kids iris and
Jay they really didn't or maybe açaí I
came over exactly how to pronounce it
but they didn't really like those
characters that much and so as a result
they may not be a huge fan of other of
Wally West's kids being in the story but
the fact remains we get to see the pre
flashpoint Wally West and so I think
that's really going to take over its
going to overshadow any kind of or deal
with his kids or anything like that so
people are going to sort of enjoy that
but again we actually what we gonna
finding out is that Wally West is I
guess him he's gonna be teaming up with
flash back from the zoo crew we're just
actually kind of a cool concept again
we'll get more in depth into them and
they'll be going against Wonder Woman
the flashpoint version of Wonder Woman
so this is actually kind of shaping up
to be a pretty cool story I think in
terms of what we're gonna be seeing here
now coming up next I think is one of the
coolest convergence stories and that's
Superman number one because we get free
flashpoint Superman back and so many
people were happy about this so many
people were excited about this I was as
well but more so than that we of course
also pick up with Superman's
relationship with Lois Lane and the fact
that she's preggers and so the cool
thing here is now we have Superman who
has something to fight for
more so than simply just saving lives
now again he is a character who's lost
his abilities he lost his uh his powers
when the dome went up once the dome came
down he gained his powers back but more
so than that what we're actually gonna
be seeing is that Superman is not gonna
be fighting a single character he's not
gonna be fighting a single villain like
we've seen with with I guess with the
flash and and so on with Wally West he's
actually he looks like he's gonna be
taking on the entire group of
superheroes from the flashpoint universe
he's gonna be taking on all those
various people now we know that Wonder
Woman that Aquaman they're kind of off
doing their own thing fighting different
people and so it looks like his conflict
is gonna be limited to to everybody else
that was part of the flashpoint group
and so I'm actually really looking
forward to this to see how it is that
Superman from pre flashpoint would
compare to his flashpoint counterparts
will you be able to hold his own this is
what I'm really kind of excited about
now the next one is one that's a little
bit interesting it's a not one that I
was really on board with too much as a
story began to progress but this is a
Harley Quinn number one now Harley Quinn
number one give us a look at pre
flashpoint Harley Quinn but this one
again is kind of a story that I felt
sort of kind of delved into the realm of
nonsense and and kind of silliness again
this basically focuses on the life of
Harley Quinn when she's not as I guess
not that the girlfriend of the Joker
when she's trying to pursue a normal
life and in truth it's really legitimate
when people say that nothing really
happens in this story because untrue
that doesn't there's really nothing that
happens here she's basically just kind
of trying to live her life and then
suddenly poison ivy Catwoman kind of
inject themselves into the story and say
well the domes are down people are gonna
start fighting yes so now we've got to
go fight other people we got to protect
our city and it seems as though I guess
keeping in with the king
element I guess a silly element of
Harley Quinn now she's gonna be going
against the zoo crew against that that
universe of sentient animals and so
that's gonna be kind of interesting to
see how it goes off I think with Wally
West pairing up with Fastback who was a
member of the zoo crew that provides a
more reasonable story because you have
seriousness countered with kind of
silliness in the nature of fash back
fastback in the sense that he's a
sentient animal that's the connection to
the Speed Force with Harley Quinn you
have a silly character combined with a
silly concept and I think that's gonna
kind of prove to be disastrous but we'll
see what happens I mean I think it's too
early to judge at this point because we
actually seen anything happen yet now
the final solicitation that I want to
offer in this video is the idea of
Arsenal or I guess of the Titans
now the Titans focuses on Arsenal on
Donna Troy and on Starfire these are the
three main characters of this story this
is actually really kind of cool because
it gives us an idea of what Arsenal
would be like if he didn't have the
ability to use his arm and couldn't
actually be a character that could be
effective and he basically couldn't be a
sidekick of the arrow he couldn't carry
out the same kind of things he did when
he was a pre flashpoint Arsenal so this
is really kind of cool here um the other
thing is it deals a lot with the idea of
him losing his daughter of her being out
of the picture this is basically just
kind of picking up with pre flashpoint
Arsenal but more so than that but we'll
also find is that he and Starfire and
Donna Troy will be going against the
extremists of Angora now this is not the
same group that Batman's going against
this is a different extremis of anger or
a different group entirely now initially
I wasn't aware of that I actually saw
the video from Joel of a comic book cast
where he had done his review on the
Titans which was really beneficial and
helping me help me a company grips with
it but the fact that means that this is
a great a great offering for the week of
convergence number one it's a great
combination to bring back some older
characters some great stories to get
this kind of again final hurrah for a
lot of these characters because a lot of
these characters just won't make the cut
they just won't be coming back but I
think that combining it with some
elements like the zoo crew and so on
will really kind of provide this balance
of comedy alongside the very serious
tone that a lot of these stories are
going to take with that being said I'm
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end I hope you guys enjoyed it let me
know what you guys think about videos
like this and I will catch you guys
later